La dernière fois, sur Instagram, je suis tombé sur quelqu'un qui avait posté une photo de moi avec le texte : (photo)
Alors déjà, ben, merci beaucoup...
Et puis j'me suis dis que je pourrais faire plein d'autres têtes.
*bâillement*
*cris de douleur*
Bonj... Bonjour...
Ah..Ah Ça.. Ah oui, y'a quelqu'un qui... *mimes* C'est lui..
Hein?!  Euh... oui, oui, oui je le veux
Humpf!
En fait il faut juste appuyer sur le bout...
Merci
Mmh...
Oui
*rires*
Bah ça va...
Ah Oui Ah Oui Bahhhh Mais je... Ouais Mais Oui C'est Bon
Bonjour
Bon! Alors
Forcément, forcément, je... je suis con
*gémissements*
Bon, écoutez
Euh... Non, oui c'est important mais je, on vas
Je vais, euh...
Une paire mon gars, elle avait un cul...
Ah, euh
Mais euh, limite trop même
*gémissements de peur*
oui...
C'est... C'est
C'est, c'est tout droit
Juste derrière le...
La première à droite
*gémissements de peur* Je regrette...
Euh... oui, oui je le veux
Quoi, c'est quoi ton problême, qu'est ce que tu veux?
Oui, pardon, pardon désolé, ça me... pardon... Oui c'est? Pour le...
Oh non, pas encore... Pff...
*Soundtrack du Roi Lion*
Non...
Pffff
*cris de joie* OH PUTAIN OH OH PUTAIN
Super...
Ma vie est superbe, et je disparais encore, putain...
Vous pouvez retrouver toutes les réactions au GIF animés sur tatêtequand.tumblr.com
Et vous pouvez les utiliser sur twitter, Facebook ou ailleurs
Par exemple: "moi quand mes parents me demandent comment ça va à l'école"
Et n'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en l'air, ça soutient énormément